[Music]
it's day three of summer game first and
we just saw the xbox bethesda showcase
and one of the biggest games to be
announced was pentameter am i saying
that right yes what does pentiment mean
pentiment is uh it's either pentimento
or pentiment it refers to a painting in
which
there is one painting on top of another
one it could be details that were
changed figures moved around or hidden
um sometimes it was done for
uh sort of political reasons or to
remove a character or just change
something for the preference of the
person who owned it what is this game
actually about and how do you play it
yeah so you the game is about an artist
named andreas mahler and it is set in
16th century bavaria in the holy roman
empire you are an artist who is
finishing his journeyman years and about
to become a master and you're kind of
doing some odd jobs and you're you're in
a monastic scriptoria at this point in
time in history there are very few
monasteries that are still producing
manuscripts but uh there's one that
desperately needs some help you help
them out but while you're doing it a
murder occurs and your friend and mentor
at the uh scriptorium is accused of it
and so andreas takes it upon himself to
figure out who the real killer is
um and then he becomes involved in a
conspiracy that goes over 25 years of
time so it actually spans several
generations and the the gameplay is it's
much like a game like oxenfree or night
in the woods where you spend most of
your time walking around the environment
uh meeting with characters talking to
them
learning the motives and motivations
that people might have had to commit the
murder looking at evidence and then sort
of presenting it to the ultimate
arbiters because you're not a judge
you're an artist i got the kind of
through line over that and it's exciting
but then you also said a word a bunch of
words that i did not understand so i was
like okay this is gonna be one of those
games where i learned something about
history it's worth pointing out that um
we know that a lot of people who come to
this game might like the subject matter
or the idea of the subject matter but
not might not be familiar with it so we
do have an in-game glossary that's very
easy to access so if we start talking
about martin luther or aristotle or
something of that nature you can sort of
just hit tab or click on the thing and
it'll show you who is ourselves yeah
this is this is who this person is and
so we we don't assume
a ton of familiarity with these subject
matters and we do hope that the story is
engrossing and that you kind of pick up
and learn things about this time period
along the way it definitely feels like a
passion project but like how do you kind
of
reconcile doing this as a studio doing
something like this when you know the
world around you is like new vegas too
and like they see your name attached to
it and they know your pedigree and then
this comes out you have to like almost
present and explain that to a lot of
people right to be like this kind of
thing we want to do
yeah i mean i think that people who
follow me know that this is the sort of
thing that i want to do
um but again like you know i i've been
making
essentially two types of games for a
long time i've made top-down or
isometric style uh party-based
role-playing games fantasy role-playing
games and you know something like
fallout new vegas and those are great
and those are big teams and i've been
doing that for 20 years and i just
wanted to take a little break and do
something very small i genuinely love uh
history and i love this this specific
period of history and i think that a lot
of people i've seen have referred to it
as a medieval murder mystery which is
not quite true it's it's i don't
it's early modern so it's it's it's the
transition point
actually the internet yeah i did i know
but it is the transition point between
the medieval period and the modern
period so so it's the renaissance and
all the difficult things that came along
with that the reformation is happening
so martin luther is reeling against the
catholic church uh the peasants
uprisings are happening and that's like
a big deal um throughout especially
germany
and uh yeah i think it's fascinating
it's a it's a period of history that's
not covered a lot in games
and if it is it's usually not in this
way and so
um i wanted to make a story that's
really focused on the personal
interactions between andreas the monks
the nuns all the people in the village
that are nearby but then tie it into
these larger trends in history that are
occurring i really want people to be
drawn in by the story itself and the
characters and then all the other
historical stuff is just things that
they sort of pick up along the way and
if they don't if they don't like do a
deep dive on facino and and like all
these other like writers that's totally
cool they can just be like cool got it
anyway the way you described that my
brain was translating it as oh
relationships between certain people
factions
kind of sounds like new vegas in a way
where you're going and like is it is it
fair to say that that kind of how's the
dna of you know obsidian and and your
kind of style of design and writing and
narrative kind of represented in this it
seems like that is how you want it right
like the uh the relationship with the
church and et cetera et cetera yeah i
think um i mean we don't have like
faction systems or things like that but
um
character interactions uh character
motivation storytelling is really at the
heart of this stuff um making the player
make difficult choices is also like a
key obsidian thing that people are going
to see in the game so one of the things
that's come up is
you're not in charge of investigating
this murder but you take it upon
yourself and when you give evidence
like people say like if you if you point
someone out and tell the the archdeacon
who's investigating what happened that
person's probably gonna die
and we're very upfront like you're not
gonna know who the real killer is you
have to make your best guess
and
you can make that choice based off you
believe that genuinely they are the
person that did it you can think that
they're the person that should should be
executed you just don't like them yeah
um you could think it's the person that
the people are going to be least upset
about disappearing but whatever your
choices are that will then play out over
the next years that that happen in the
game and presumably it has like a ripple
effect yeah the world around you yeah we
with one of the unique opportunities
about this is because it's in a small
community uh there's the monitors
there's the abbey and then the town
uh and it's over 25 years we can show
generations uh of people
and uh and sometimes generations of
people cut short because for example
they got killed
um and we really like that possibility
and potential for choice and consequence
and also just seeing how characters
develop and react over time that way is
it is there like a case of you know when
you have these moments where you're like
there's no real historical evidence for
this we kind of have to fill it in a bit
like you also
feel like a responsibility that we
should call out the fact that we didn't
like we kind of have fudged this a bit
or we we've is there a way do you do
that because i know like personally
like a lot of gamers like we're probably
learning you know things from games and
assuming taking it for fact yeah but you
wouldn't believe the amount of people
that know like italian renaissance
history because they've played it oh
absolutely yeah i mean that's one of the
things i think is really cool about
assassin's creed yeah so it's like i
mean but then also you get people like
yeah there's a guy who in the history
called uh
and you get some italian like historian
being like what are you talking about
yeah so like do you feel like a
responsibility to like do you even have
a section where it's like here's all the
stuff that we kind of fudged like no we
don't have anything like that but like i
said when it when it's very unusual or
very strange we try to at least address
it if people are sort of interested
um you know maybe someday we'll do it
behind the scenes where i can say like
okay that and that thing and that thing
well finally um how does it feel to have
it out there finally and i've seen like
the responses have been very positive
from it like you've had it in your mind
for a long time now it's out there how's
it feel it's really great um
i mean obviously waiting to announce a
game is always uh
sort of nerve-wracking but with this
game also there because it is so unusual
as a game and for obsidian and for me i
knew that there was a potential that
people just wouldn't
respond well to it
but yeah i mean like in the in the 15
minutes between the the
the launch and me going like on twitter
it seems to be pretty good but at least
you get regardless of the outcome at
least you you know you scratch that h in
your head that's been there for so long
yeah which must inevitably be feel good
and if anything you get self fulfillment
right well yeah and and like my stance
with this always is it's a niche game
and it's fine as long as it finds its
audience and at least from the response
so far that i've seen online there are
people that want to play the game so so
as long as there is a healthy group of
people that are like i really want to
play this game then that's good for me
well josh i want to play it i'm sure
i'll become a smarter person from
playing and i look forward to it thank
you so much for your time thank you i
appreciate it uh keep it games for more
on pantomime in the weeks months and
hours i guess to follow and we'll see
you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]